good evening I'm poppy Harlow and you're
watching the first news Tanna con you're
sick of hearing about it
I'm sick of talking about it so let's
just jump into it trust me
there's some pretty spicy news in here
that you need to know that for those who
don't know Tana mango the youtuber made
a meet-up convention at the very same
time as VidCon at the very same location
as VidCon and me ignoring all the lies
that were involved it was to summarize
it a disaster
thousands of young fans were waiting
outside in the Sun with no food no water
no cover for hours until eventually the
event got entirely canceled
disappointing fans that thought that
were gonna meet their favorite creators
you know probably parents and themself
obviously spending a lot of money on
travel the hotel and the ticket themself
we should were just rendered useless
the first blame that we were told was
that 15,000 people just magically showed
up unexpectedly and there's no way for
anyone to just handle that situation and
a lot of people bought it I even bought
it at some point but later it came out
that that was a lie from a police
statement from the city garden and Grove
police department saying that 4,000
people tickets were sold and only
thousand people could actually fit in
the event so then it caused a lot of
drama and speculation as to did Tana
know about this that good times the
event organizer did they know about this
and there was a lot of back-and-forth
going on and it wasn't really sure what
exactly went wrong who is responsible of
these two parties was at Ana
was it Michael from good times well now
we have the answer don't you just love a
nice conclusion thanks to Shane Dawson's
latest video he's a close friend with
tena Mungo
so we get the inside truth and sorry not
just the truth about 10m ongo but the
real truth about Tana now the video is
41 minute long and I will let I
definitely recommend watching it if
you're interested but I will however
summarize it for you
it's basically 30 minutes of incoherent
ugly sobbing does anyone know what she's
saying
scientists are still trying to figure
this out I'm poppy Harlow and rest
assure I will do my best we are working
around the clock to decipher in this way
in my opinion show you did a really good
job it's giving the most balanced view
on this situation as he possibly could
that being said they are friends it's
never going to be a balanced
presentation and in my opinion that was
a lot of Tanna constantly going after
Michael and deflecting blame towards him
she doesn't have many options to play at
this point because I don't know should I
keep trusting my own he keeps the over I
don't understand anything and you still
have not answered my last like ten
questions to you you just keep diverting
the subject because you don't let him
speak
Jesus Christ and I'm sitting there like
it doesn't matter I can agree that you
feels betrayed but you know she thought
the event would handle it
it doesn't matter none of it matters and
I'll tell you why because they both knew
they both knew they both knew both Tana
and goodtimes knew that the event only
held a thousand people they both knew
that they sold tickets for five thousand
which isn't surprising anytime I work
with a company the first thing that
report is how many things did we sell or
how many bubbala did we sell how many
units did return what profit did we make
it's pretty relevant information and the
fact that they're pretending like they
didn't know any of this
good capacity maybe drop into 3000 we
could but are we gonna be more
responsible and drop it from five
thousand to three thousand which is
still three times to many people they
both knew they also knew that they will
tell only held a thousand two hundred
but what is it I haven't said it fifty
two hundred right now I love that I love
that for us yeah do you love it now Tana
and the final bit that annoyed me so
much the final clip that is so annoying
to me and I can its let's just play it
it would be really really cool to have
people outside waiting to get in let
people love to be oppressed outside yes
Tana Mungo people love to be oppressed
outside
[Music]
people love to be oppressed outside Tana
hello
in case you're watching I hope you are I
have a message for you you say in
Shane's video many times like you want
to make it right you might you want to
make the situation better but you don't
know how because it's too overwhelming
they let so many people down and I want
to make it right but I it's crazy this
is not something I ever thought would
happen and I don't know what to do but I
have to make it right you're in luck
because I know how to make this right
and I'm not saying that sarcastically
and ironically here's what you gotta do
delete your channel you clearly don't
deserve to have an audience the people
being oppressed outside was your
audience the people that care for you
the people that paid money to see you to
me this is a perfect example of greed of
ego and greed of money being combined
and creating this giant mess and
ultimately everyone loses except me
because I get content to criticize I
mean I had fun to be oppressed outside
next news every once in a while a deaf
occurs in relation to a video game
usually it's in regards of someone
playing for 40 hours straight
even playing for days on straight and
lately we've been seen movement more and
more towards the idea that gaming is
something harmful the White House for
example exclaiming that video games
causes school shootings World Health
Organization classifying gaming disorder
as a mental health condition we talked
about this on this channel but we
haven't seen before a psychological
death related to video games at least as
far as I'm concerned until now
good morning we're gonna start this
morning by talking about a free online
game after police and a coroner have
warned about the risks of it to children
it's called doki-doki literature club
and it starts like a dating game set in
a high school and features a group of
animated girls in a book club things do
turn sinister with characters self
harming and
themselves it's said to be suitable for
players aged 13 or over it was launched
last year and was downloaded 2 million
times in the first 4 months an inquest
will be held into the death of a 15 year
old called Ben Warmsley from Bari whose
father said the game dragged his son in
so he was reported in the Manchester
news that a 15 year old boy was found
dead now his dad and coroner have warned
about the horror online game he was
playing doki-doki literature club this
has been covered in a lot of different
media don't let your child play
doki-doki literature club before reading
this it's a bit late now isn't it a
quote from the father is saying that Ben
was growing up fast
it's hard for parents but this needs to
be highlighted there is no confirmation
yet but we believe that the game could
be linked to Ben's death so they're not
outright blaming the game for the cause
of death they're just saying that it's a
potential cost that isn't really what
gets echoed through the media and
doki-doki is the front phase of this
side event because of that but what I've
noticed while reading through a couple
articles is that the description of the
game doesn't really fit what the
gameplay actually is you know I played
the game on my channel it was very
popular people really liked it it's an
amazing game in my opinion and the
constant point that's being reiterated
in these article is that the game will
not leave you alone it will drag you in
that's doesn't fit doki-doki in my
opinion but fine then it's pointed out
in another article that the game is an
online game which it isn't I don't know
where they got that from and the father
describing the game last the character
befriends and love you and give you
tasks to do but if you do not do them
they turn nasty doesn't really fit
either and then finally after reading
this the game was linked with his mobile
phone and he would be contacted by text
message during day and night often
waking him up that's when I realized
they're not talking about doki-doki
literature clock they're talking about
another game it's even shown here in
another article they're talking about
mystic messenger a game where you
message people a game that will give you
notifications at random points at least
I think that's what I imagine is what he
meant a game that drags you in a game
that's free it all fits
it all fits perfectly if you go to
doki-doki sweb site
the game doesn't lure you in it's not
some sort of con to portray us this
colorful game and it's really a massive
plot twist to anyone that it's a horror
game people know you go on the website
and it's tagged as a psychological
horror and the first text that shows up
is that the game is not suitable for
children and those who easily disturb
but then I thought it was interesting
because in contrast to these other
gaming related death this game is
actually very short it's not focused to
drag you in or keep you playing or keep
you hooked on the game like many other
games are designed to be these days and
after this article came out another
parent came forward and said the same
thing that their child had had problems
sleeping stopped eating there was no
clear signs of what would happen but
there were many things happening with my
son and doki-doki is just one part of it
but I need the death of my son to have
some meaning now I can't possibly
imagine what it's like to lose a child
and I don't know the hardship of what
it's like to being a parent and I'm not
blaming any parent sometimes horrible
things just happen for no good reason
but in my opinion one videogame doesn't
drive you to do this at least not
doki-doki literature Club it's just not
a reasonable claim and I'm gonna put on
my sonic sense mean thumbs up here and
pretty pipe says as a parent you should
be equally focused on what your child is
doing online or in front of the computer
as you are focused on what they're doing
in their everyday life I think a lot of
parents don't realize that kids are
practically growing up in front of their
computers and it's a massive part of
their social interaction to some extent
it needs to be monitored to prevent
these sort of things from happening
and the fact that the parent in this
incident described another game and
calling it doki-doki literature club
shows to some extent at least that they
didn't know what the child was up to or
at least didn't understand it and I
understand that it's confusing as well
but it what really amazes me here is how
poorly this was covered by the media
with almost every single news article
all pointing to doki-doki when clearly
that's not it what are your thoughts
what are your opinions I want to hear
them let me know in the comments kind of
a downer it's not the most fun pleasant
news to talk about but I think it's
important nonetheless and finally I
appreciate all the support on pew news
[Music]
[Applause]